[موسيقى]
بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت الرياضه
صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
من سد كاخفكا الى خط لتصدير الامونيا
الفوضى تغرق اوكرانيا وتسمم اجوائها وسط
تبادل الاتهامات من كياب وموسكو
في السودان الاشتباكات العنيفه تتجدد في
الخرطوم وماسي المرضى لا تتوقف بعد وفاه
الجميع مرضى غسيل الكلى في مستشفى الجنينه
تجدد الخلاف بين اسرائيل وامريكا بعد
تصريحات كمال هاريس نائبه بايدن حول اصلاح
القضاء
حرائق كندا تصل نيويوركا الدخان يغطي مبنى
الامم المتحده ويوقف رحله جويه بسبب عيدان
الرؤيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه الحرب
الاوكرانيه تاخذ مسارات متشعبه فبعد كارثه
تفجير سدك خوفكا عرفت الساعات الماضيه
تفجيرا جديدا استهدف خطا انابيب لنقل
الامونيا يتعلق الامر بخط انابيب يربط بين
مدينتي الروسيه واوديسا الاوكرانيه تفجير
اتهمت
بتدبيره حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه فجرت خط انابيب
طوليا خلال عمل ارهابي ادى الى اصابه
العديد من المدني وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه دائما ان التفجير تم في منطقه
خاركيف التي استعاد الجيش الاوكراني
السيطره عليها كليا في خريف عام 2022
في حوالي الساعه التاسعه مساء بتوقيت
موسكو فجرت مجموعه استطلاع الاوكرانيه خط
انابيب بتولياتي للامونيا بالقرب من منطقه
خركيف ونتيجه لهذا العمل الارهابي وقعت
اصابات في صف سكان المدنيين وقد تم
تزويدهم بالمساعده الطبيه اللازمه وفي
الوقت الحالي يتم تصريف بقايا الامونيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر الاجزاء المتضرره
من خط الانابيب
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
قالت في بيان لها ان اصل انابيب الامونيا
الذي تم تفجيره في منطقه خارك في اوكرانيا
سيستغرق من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
وفقا للمعلومات المتاحه في الخامس من
يونيو تم تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
في منطقه خاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا نعم انها
نفس منشاه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه التي تم
ذكرها مرارا وتكرارا كجزء من اتفاق حبوب
البحر الاسود وبسبب استهدافها تم اخراج
احدى محطات الضخ من الخدمه وتشغيل صمامات
الاغلاق ومع ذلك تسربت المواد الخام وف
تقييم الاولي ستستغرق اعمال السياره
والاصلاح ما يقرب من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
بعيدا عن تعيش منطقه خرسون حاله استنفار
القصوى على خلفيه تفجير سدك تبادل
الاتهامات تواصل بين طرفي النزاع حيث حملت
كل جهه المسؤوليه للاخرى الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ادلى باول تعليق بخصوص
الكارثه حيث قال انكياف وبناء على توجيهات
من الغرب تواصل تصعيد الوضع واستخدام
الاساليب الارهابيه مضيفا ان الهجوم على
محطه مثال على ذلك اما الرئيس الاوكراني
فقد اعرب عن خشيته من حدوث اضرار بيئيه
جسيمه لا سيما وان الاف الحيوانات محاصره
بسبب الفيضانات فيما وصف رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع الاوكراني لوف الاتهامات
الروسيه بتورط اوكرانيا في تدمير السد
بالامر السخيف مؤكدا ان الجيش الاوكراني
لم يكن متواجدا في المنطقه وقت حادثه
تدمير السد
الاتهامات باننا وراء تدمير السد امر
مستحيل فعليا في ذلك الوقت لم يكن جيشنا
ولا مواطننا متواجدين في المنطقه للاسف
الشديد تم احتلال المنطقه منذ مايو الماضي
من قبل الروس لذا فان القول باننا فعلنا
ذلك في وجودهم هو امر سخيف
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه اهان ماليار
قالت ان تفجير سد كخوفكا ادى الى تدمير
مواقع عسكريه روسيه في خيلصون واضافه
روسيا تسببت في اضرار كبيره لقواتها
بتفجيرها سد كخوفكا وحسب نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني فان السيل الناتج عن
تدمير السد ادى الى انجراف الالغام الى
مناطق القوات الروسيه في خرسون بعد تفجير
سد كخوفكح
على صعيد الانساني يواصل الطرفان بذله
مجهودات لاجلاء المدنيين وبحسب رئيس
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمنطقه خرسون
تم اجلاء 1700 شخص من مناطق الفيضانات
الخاضعه للسيطره الاوكرانيه وافادت
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها ستضطر لاجلاء
اكثر من 17 الف مدني من المناطق المتضرره
على الجانب الروسي اجلت السلطات حوالي
1300 شخص واعلنت حاله الطوارئ في الجزء
الذي تسيطر عليه من منطقه خرسون
[موسيقى]
معنا من كييف غيث احمد مناف عضو هيئه
الاعلام الحربيه الاوكرانيه سيد غيث اهلا
بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه
ما حجم الاضرار التي تم حصرها حتى الان من
تفجير سد كخوفكا وكذلك خط الامونيا
لكم ولكافه المشاهدين الكرام بالفعل لا
يمكنني انا ان اتحدث عن الحجم الماساوي
الذي الان يشهده مواطنون الاوكران داخل
المناطق الجنوبيه
بلغت ارتفاع مستوى المياه في منطقه خرسون
بالتحديد اكثر من ثلاثه ونصف مترا كما ان
ايضا يحاول الان فريق الاجلاء على مستوى
متطوعون ايضا مدنيون بعدد 1500 متطوع حتى
هذه اللحظه يحاول اجراء المدنيون من تلك
المناطق ومن تلك المدن التي خرجت بالفعل
من الخدمه مباشره هناك منازل
اختفت عن الوجود هناك منازل
غمرتها المياه بشكل كامل هناك ايضا ابنيه
وصلت ارتفاع المياه لاكثر الدور الثالث
الوضع ماساويه لغايه الان تحدثت مجموعه من
منظمات المجتمع المدني عن اسفها وايضا
ادانه ما قام به الاحتلال الروسي حسب
وصفهم بانهم قاموا بتفجير تلك
السد وهو سد كهرومائي ثاني اكبر سد موجود
في اوروبا الشرقيه وهو سد نظرك الذي كان
يمد المدن بالمياه العذبه وايضا شبه جزيره
القرم كانت ايضا تستمد المياه من تلك
السد الموجود هناك وايضا عندما نذهب
ونشاهد حسب ما تحدث مجموعه من المحللون
العسكريون بعد ان قامت روسيا بتسريب
مجموعه من الفيديوهات التي يؤكد عمليه
الانفجار وكيف حدث هذا الانفجارين اغلب
المحللون الغرب وايضا الاوكران برهنوا بان
الانفجار كان من داخل محطه التوليد او
داخل المركز الاداره التابع لتلك اسد اي
الانفجار كان ناتجا عن استهداف مباشر من
قبل الغام تم وضعها مسبقا هناك ولكن غيث
حتى الان لا توجد تاكي دات غربيه بان
روسيا هي المسؤوله يعني بشكل صريح عن عن
هذا التفجير تفجير السد كذلك طبعا الجانب
الروسي ينفي الاتهامات بانه يقف وراء هذا
التفجير فهل الجانب الاوكراني لديه ادله
دامغه تدعم حجته بان روسيا هي التي تقف
وراء تفجير السد
نعم بكل تاكيد هذا ما صرح به الرئيس
الاوكراني عندما ادعنا بشكل كامل وايضا
اتهم روسيا مباشره بهذا الانفجار حيث ذكر
بانه لديه الادله والبراهين بالاضافه الى
ذلك وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ارسل خطاب رسميا الى مجلس الامن
واعلن او طلب انعقاد جلسه طارئه لادانه
روسيا عن وصفه بالارهاق او اجراءة الحرب
البشعه التي حدثت في اوكرانيا بالاضافه
الى ذلك برهنوا بان هناك مجموعه من الادله
التي تدين روسيا بتلك التفكيرات كما ان
الرئيس الاوكراني ذكر في هذا اللقاء
الاخير بانه قد حذر الغرب وحذر الامم
المتحده منذ عام كامل بان روسيا قامت
بتفخيخ تلك
او تلك السد الموجود في اقصى جنوبي
الاراضي الاوكرانيا ولكن ان دعيتني ان
اتحدث هناك تصعيد اخر خطين وهو
تصعيد مفاعل
ذا برو حيث انخفض مستوى المياه وهذا على
طريق ما تحدث به الهيئه الحاكمه العسكريه
لمنطقه زفروجا حيث اكدت بان هناك انخفاض
مستوى المياه في احدى
على ما اعتقد تستخدم للتبريد تبريد محطه
صحيح بالفعل بالفعل اثني مترا انخفض مستوى
مياه الضغط التبريد التابع لمحطه وقد يؤجج
هذا الموقف الى انفجار كارثي نووي قد لا
يحمد عقباه من قبل الطرفين سواء كان
الروسي او الاوكراني من هو المسبب حتى هذه
اللحظه هذا الانفجار قد ربما يكون طرف
ثالث او ربما يكون احدى الطرفين الذي لهم
من قاموا باستهداف المباشر غيث احمد مناف
عضو هيئه الاعلام الحربيه الاوكرانيه من
كيف شكرا جزيلا
والى جانب تفجير سد كخوفك وانابيب
الامونيا لا يزال الحديث متواصلا بخصوص
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني المرتقب هجوم
تسعى موسكو جاهده الى ايقافه او تعطيله
نائبه رئيسي مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتريديف
تحدث عن الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني حيث قال
ان موسكو لن تتفاجا في حال تم الهجوم لكن
الذي اشتهر برسائله التهديديه منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه حذر في الوقت نفسه من ما
غبت الاستهانه بالجيش الاوكراني سيما في
ظل توفره على اسلحه متطوره وبعيدا عن
الهجوم المضاد صعد لهجته بشكل واضح ودعا
الى الاطاحه الكامله بالنظام النازي في
كييف على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
وهذا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لا يزال
يشغل بال الجميع في اوكرانيا وسط تضارب
للانباء حول موعد تنفيذه فبينما تؤكد
موسكو بان الهجوم قد بدا بالفعل لا تزال
في ذلك نفي جاء مره اخرى على لسان اوليكسي
مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني
والذي قال لان الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني
لم يبدا بعد قال ايضا ان الموضوع بيد
الجيش الاوكراني مشيرا الى ان الجميع سوف
يعرف موعد الهجوم المضاد عند بدايته
[موسيقى]
ملفنا التالي في اخبار الساعه السودان
تتوالى الايام وتتشابه هناك فالاقتتال لا
يزال مستمرا بين طرفي النزاع الاشتباكات
العنيفه تواصلت بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وصف استمرار لتحليق
الطيران الحربي بالعاصمه الخرطوم ووصل
الاقتتال هذه المره الى منطقه مجمع
اليرموك وهو احدى شركات التصنيع الحربيه
التابعه للجيش بجنوب مدينه الخرطوم كما
امتدت الاشتباكات الى مستودع الشجره والذي
يعد ثاني اكبر مستودع بالعاصمه السودانيه
للغاز والمواد البتروليه
[موسيقى]
وكلما استمرت الحرب كلما تواصلت مقاس
المدنيين الابرياء فويلات الحرب عبثت
بمصير الكثير من الاطفال والمرضى بهذا
الخصوص كشف وزير الصحه بولايه شرق دارفور
عوفات سته اطفال حديثي الولاده بسبب نقص
في الامدادات كما اكدت اللجنه الطبيه
لمدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
وفات جميع مرضى غسيل الكلى في المدينه
وذلك بعد خروج جميع المستشفيات والمراكز
الصحيه عن الخدمه تقول نقابه الاطباء ان
66% من المستشفيات الواقعه في مناطق
الاشتباكات توقفت عن العمل نتيجه لتعرضها
للقصف والخلاء القصري وضعف الامدادات
الطبيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
حرائق كندا تصل نيويورك دخان يغطي مبنى
الامم المتحده ويوقف رحلات جويه بسبب
انعدام الرؤيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قلى الكرملين رئيس روسيا
بحث هاتفيا مع ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ملف اسواق الطاقه العالميه
وسبل استقرارها كما اوضح الكريم لنفوتين
والامير محمد بن سلمان ثمنا التعاون في
اطار اوبكلاس كما ناقش بناء العلاقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه والمشاريع في مجالات
الاستثمار والطاقه
[موسيقى]
قررت اداره طيران الفيدرالي الامريكي
توقيف رحلات جويه الى مدينه نيويورك بسبب
ضعف الرؤيه الناتج عن حرائق الغابات وقالت
اداره الطيران ان الرحلات الجويه المتجهه
الى مطار نيويورك اما توقفت مؤقتا او
تاخرت عن موعد وصولها فيما غطى دخان
الحرائق سماء نيويورك ومبنى الامم المتحده
اذا مشاهدينا نذهب لنلقي نظره على اجواء
نيويورك في هذه اللحظات اذا الان كما
تشاهدون ما تزال الاجواء مغبره بشكل كبير
جدا مشاهدينا نيويورك كانت قد تصدرت المدن
الاكثر تلوثا في العالم يوم الثلاثاء وهذا
بسبب حرائق كندا رياح قويه محمله بالتربه
والغبار وصلت الى نيويورك وادت الى هذا
المشهد وكما ذكرنا في الخبر السابق جرى
ايقاف الكثير من الرحلات الجويه بسبب
انعدام الرؤيه وكذلك ارتفاع درجه التلوث
في هوائي نيويورك ادت بالمؤسسات التعليميه
والعديد من النشاطات الاخرى كذلك الى
التوقف بسبب ارتفاع منسوب التلوث في اجواء
نيويورك الامريكيه طبعا كما كنا تابعنا في
الايام القليله الماضيه كانت موجه من
الحرائق اشتعلت بشكل كبير في مناطق
هي عده الان بدات يعني تؤثر على مناطق
اخرى وتصل الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
النتيجه الصوره التي تشاهدون الان والتي
ان خفت قليلا بالمقارنه مع اوقات مع
الساعات السابقه كانت الاجواء اكثر تلوثا
والرؤيه كذلك اقل بكثير من المشهد الذي
نشاهده الان ولكن هذه هي النتيجه وسنعود
ربما خلال اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله
لمتابعه الوضع عن كثب من نيويورك مع
ضيوفنا من هناك
[موسيقى]
قالت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي مع
امريكا الذي عقد في الرياض بحثا تكثيف
العمل الخليجي الامريكي والتنسيق المشترك
في العديد من القضايا الاقميه والدوليه
واضافت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان
الاجتماع تتطرق الى العديد من القضايا
السياسيه والامنيه كما تناول الاجتماع
وجهات النظر حيال الجهود المبذوله للوصول
الى حلول عادله للعديد من الازمات التي
تمر بها منطقه الشرق الاوسط والعالم بما
يسهم في تعزيز الامن والسلم الدوليه
وخلال الاجتماعه مع وزراء خارجيه دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي في الرياض اكد انطوني
بلينكن ان منطقه الخليج العربي هي في قلب
رؤيه الولايات المتحده لشرق اوسط اكثر
استقرارا
كما اكد الرئيس بايدن خلال زيارته لجده في
العام الماضي فالولايات المتحده باقيه في
المنطقه وسنبقى مستثمرين في شراكاتنا معكم
جميعا من اجل بناء مستقبل مشرق في الشرق
الاوسط وبلا شك فان منطقه الخليج العربي
هي قلب رؤيتنا لشرق اوسط اكثر استقرارا
وامانا وازدهارا واندماجا نحن نعمل معا من
اجل التوصل الى حل للنزاع في اليمن
بلاينكن شدد كذلك على اهميه وحده الاراضي
السوريه وسيادتها وضروره خفض التوترات في
فلسطين والسودان من اجل ضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه
نسعى لايجاد حل سياسي للوضع في سوريا يضمن
وحدتها وسيادتها ويلبي طموحات شعبها
بالتوافق مع القانون الدولي ويمتثل
لقرارات مجلس الامن نحن ايضا ملتزمون بخفض
التوترات بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وابقاء افق الامل والعمل على حل الدولتين
وفي السودان واستجابه للازمه الاخيره نحن
نعمل بشكل مستمر على اسكات فوهات البنادق
والضغط لفتح ممرات المساعدات الانسانيه من
اجل مساعده الشعب السوداني على تحقيق
اماله والنقطه التي نركز عليها هي ان
انخراطنا معكم انتم شركائنا في الخليج
[موسيقى]
معنا الان بالعوده الى موضوع التلوث
الكبير الحاصل في نيويورك وتعطل الرحلات
الجويه بسبب الرياح المحمله
بالتربه القادمه من كندا بسبب الحرائق
معنا من نيويورك الان الصحفي طارق الشامي
طارق قبل قليل او الان بالاحرى على شاشه
العربيه نحن نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
لمدينه نيويورك حيث ما تزال الاجواء
المغبره تلف سماء المدينه المزيد عن هذه
الوضعيه الجويه السيئه في نيويورك
يعني هو ليس فقط في نيويورك وانما في
الولايات الشماليه الشرقيه طبعا كولايه هي
الولايه الاخرى الى كندا والمناطق التي
شهدت حرائق وخصوصا انها في اليوم السابق
كان هناك اكثر من 150 حريق في يوم واحد
اكثر من 100 حيث منهم كانت خارج خارجه عن
السيطره وهذا كله ب يعني كميات هائله من
الهواء المنور الى المناطق شمال شرق
الولايات المتحده بل وصلت حتى الى العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن
وهنا تحذيرات يعني صدرت من السلطات
الامريكيه
بتوخي الحذر و عدم الخروج من المنزل الا
في حالات الضروره هناك ايضا مراكز تعليميه
ومدارس ايضا بعدم الذهاب الى المدارس
نتيجه لهذا الامر
بسبب هذه الحرائق لون السماء حتى تحول الى
اللون البرتقالي
وهذا كله نتيجه لهذه الحرائق وكثير من
الناس بل يعني نسبه كبيره منهم في الشوارع
الان الى الخروج يضطرون الى استخدام
الكمامات حتى يحافظون على عمليه التنفس
ويلتقين بها هذا المتلوث الشديد في الهواء
الذي يؤ
دي الى
الانسان نعم شركه اي كيو ار كانت صنفت
نيويورك يوم الثلاثاء المدينه الاكثر
تلوثا في العالم بسبب هذه الاجواء طارق
الخبراء عندكم ماذا يقولون والتوقعات كذلك
الى متى يمكن ان تستمر هذه الحاله او تزول
يعني هذا يتوقف على امتداد الحرائق يعني
عن حرائق يبدو انها مستمره وهذا يعود الى
الربيع الدافئ اكثر من المعدلات الطبيعيه
نتيجه للاحترار المناخي المعروفي العالم
كله والذي يعني لا يتوقف على كندا بل ايضا
المتحده هي واحده من الدول التي يعني توجد
بها اكثر
غابات هي الاكثر كثافه في العالم وتتعرض
مساحات منها للحرائق كل عام خصوصا في غرب
الولايات المتحده في ولايه كاليفورنيا لكن
امكانيه توقف هذا التلوث لا احد يعمل لانه
هناك جهود بالتاكيد لاطفاء الحرائق
والحيلوله دون اختبارها لكن هذا لا يضمن
اشتعال حرائق اخرى وهذا
الكارثه ربما كيف تزيد
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعطيات كنت
معنا من نيويورك الصحفي طارق الدمشقي
ونبحث كذلك من بالحديث عن الخبراء ورايهم
فيما يحصل الان وهذه الصور التي نتابعها
من نيويورك معنا الخبير في المناخ دكتور
بدوي رهبان وهو مدير الحد من الكوارث
الطبيعيه في اليونسكو سابقا دكتور بدوي
اهلا بك معنا الحرائق يمكن اطفائها لكن
هذه الاجواء ودخان هذه الحرائق الذي يصل
الان الى الولايات المتحده كما نشاهد كيف
يمكن ايقافه
ليس من السهل ايقافه يجب الان ان نتعامل
مع ما يحدث بطريقه حكيمه يعني
طبعا الان الوقت الساعه هو
الاغاثه التحضير
اعطاء الترشيدات والمعلومات للمواطنين
الان هي حاله طوارئ
ولكن لا نعتقد ان هذه الحاله سوف تزول في
ساعات او في ايام للاسف
الى متى يمكن ان تدومها تستمر هذه الحاله
دكتور بدوي وفق خبرتك
ان الظروف المناخيه الحراره المرتفعه التي
هي مرتفعه بشكل استثنائي لان هناك عوامل
عده تجعل اليوم هذه المنطقه الجغرافيه
وايضا بعد انحاء العالم ايضا هنا في
اوروبا يعني تجعلها عرضه لعوامل مثل تغير
المناخ مثل ما نسميه عامل ظاهره المنيو
يعني هذه ظاهره تتعلق بطيارات بالمحيطات
التي تشكل تقلبات مناخيه هذا ما نعرفه
الان اذا نحن امام مسار امام مشهديه سوف
تدوم الان الان يجب على فراق الاطفاء ان
تكون عندها بعد ساعات الارتياح لكي
يستعدون ان يستعيدوا عافيتهم ان يكون هناك
تامين الغذاء ان يكون هناك تامين للمواد
الضروريه ان يكون هناك تامين
ان تكون فرق الاسعاف فرق الاطفاء لا تنفذ
المياه موارد المياه لها كل ذلك اذا هذه
هي الاولويه الان نعم طيب دكتور
رهبان نيويورك يعني سجلت 200 نقطه في
درجات التلوث وهو مستوى غير صحي للغايه
وفقا لشركه اي كيو ار يوم الثلاثاء بسبب
هذه الاجواء
في من يعيشون في هذه المناطق او يعني في
هكذا حالات ما الذي يجب اتخذه من اجراءات
بالنسبه للسكان للناس
من يستطيع ان لا يخرج دائما على 24 ساعه
ان لا يخرج عده ساعات خارج منزله فليفعل
ذلك من يستطيع ان يضع كمامه فليفعل ذلك من
ان الاشخاص المسنين يجب على جيرانهم ان
كانوا وحدهم ان ينتبهوا لهم ان كان هناك
العائلات يجب على الاشخاص الذين ليسوا
مسنين ان ينتبهوا على
اقربائهم المسلمين انها ارشادات يجب على
الجميع ان يستمع الان الى الارشادات التي
تعطى من السلطات الوطنيه والسلطات الوطنيه
هي عندها خبره في التعامل مع المعلومات مع
الارشادات لا يجب على المواطن ان يتعامل
بفرده ان كان يستطيع ان يستمع الى الراديو
الى التلفزيون ان لا ياخذ مبادرات لا يعرف
ما هي تبعتها هذا ما هو يجب على المواطنين
ان ان يكون عندهم هذه الثقافه طبعا هذا لا
ينشا بين ليله وضحاها ولكن ان للاسف ان
المجتمعات يجب ان تتعود في المستقبل على
هذه انواع من الاحداث المناخيه المتطرفه
شكرا جزيلا لكم دكتور بدوي رهبان مدير
الحد من الكوارث الطبيعيه في اليونسكو
سابقا
[موسيقى]
التوتر يرخي بظلاله مجددا على العلاقات
بين واشنطن وتل ابيب بعد مشاحنات بين
مسؤولي الطرفين ومره اخرى كانت الاصلاحات
القضائيه المثيره للجدل في اسرائيل سببا
في اشعال فتيل الخلاف الشراره الاولى التي
اشعلت الخلافه الجديد كانت تصريحات نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كمال هاريس الاخيره شددت
على اهميه استقلال القضاء خلال كلمه
القتها في حفل اقيم في السفاره
الاسرائيليه في واشنطن بمناسبه الذكرى
الخامسه والسبعين الاستقلال الدوله
اليهوديه تصريحنا اعاد الى الواجهه معارضه
اداره بايدن لجهود الحكومه اليمينيه
المتشدده التي يتزعمها بنيامين نتنياهو من
اجل ادخال اصلاحات على القضاء في خطوه
كانت قد قبلت باحتجاجات شديده داخل
اسرائيل
تصريح كمال هاريس لم يكن ليمر مرور الكرام
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه فسرعان ما بادرت
الى الرد وهذا عبر وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي لكوهين رد لم يخلو من الحده
حيث قال فيه الوزير الاسرائيلي ان هاريس
لن تعرف كيف تجيب في حال سؤالها عما
يزعجها بشان الاصلاح القضائي وتابع انه لا
يعرف ما اذا كانت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
قد قرات القانون ام لا مستطردا ان تقديره
انها لم تقراها
لعبه تبادل التصريحات بين واشنطن وتل ابيب
لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث دخل ايضا
السفير الامريكي لدى اسرائيل على الخطا
السفير الامريكي تم داينس اعتبر ان هاريس
صرحت باشياء تعكس رؤيه الاداره الامريكيه
حول القيام والسياسات المشتركه بين
الدولتين لعبه الشد والجذب بين الجانبين
هدات نوعا ما بعد ما عاد وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي لتلطيف الاجواء من خلال تغريده
اكد فيها ان لديه احتراما كبيرا للولايات
المتحده ولنائبه الرئيس كما لهاريس التي
تعتبر صديقه لاسرائيل وتابع وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي بالقول ان الاصلاحات القانونيه
في اسرائيل شان داخلي ملفتا الى ان هذه
القضيه لا تزال
رهن مناقشه
معنى من تل ابيب دكتور رؤوفين باركو
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي ومن واشنطن
الخبير في الشؤون الامريكيه
مرحبا بكما معنا في اخبار الساعه سيد
رؤوفين ابدا معك هل تتعامل حكومه نتنياهو
مع اداره بايدن على انها اداره سترحل في
الانتخابات القادمه ولذلك نرى يعني بالامس
كانت تعيين قلعاد سيفيك مستشارا
لنتنياهو واليوم هذا الرد من كوهين على
كما لهارس
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين
في واشنطن لا يعني انا لا اظن انه في هناك
افتراضات في الحكومه الاسرائيليه بالنسبه
لمن سوف يستعلم زمام الحكم في الاداره
الامريكيه هذا لسته بعيد وهو مش من ضمن
الاعتراف في الامر الواقع ولكنه اذا عرضت
المعطيات
فيما ستموه وكانه وزو حجم كبير وشبه كارثه
بماهيه العلاقات ما بين اسرائيل لامريكا
هذا عظيم الرصيد واقول لك يعني بين هلالين
انه المحكمه الامريكيه هي بالتعيين سياسي
مطلقا ولا يجوز
للقضاه في امريكا ان يتدخلوا في امور
تعيينهم بينما
في اسرائيل الديمقراطيه ماشيه يعني
سيد رؤوف يعني ان الاجواء يعني ليست
متوتره بين
تل ابيب واشنطن صحيح
لا في هناك نوع من توتر يعني لا اريد ان
انفي ذلك ولكن لا يتمثل ذلك
بالحدث اللي حصلت ما بين
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
وكانه في ذلك في النوع من زله لسان اقول
لا يمثل
الحكومه الايسانيه تريد عكس ما يعني صار
نتيجه هذا الكلام لانه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تريد
تقويه العلاقات مع امريكا ولا خلق علام
او التوتر وكذا انتظر الوزير على هذه
الاقوال وبنسل صفير الاسرائيلي الامريكي
في اسرائيل
اوضح بكل
وسائل كلاميه انه
العلاقات لا تزال على ما هي
وانه هذه الحاله بوصف بسيط طيب ساعود اليك
دعني اخذ ضيفه من واشنطن كذلك
عذرا على المقاطعه ساعود اليك
ما حجم الضرر الذي تراه اصاب العلاقه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه في ظل حكومه
نتنياهو الحاليه بالامس كان هناك تعيين
لمستشار وصف سابقا بايدن بانه غير كفء
لهذا المنصب واليوم هذه المشاده او
التلاسم ما بين كما لهاريس واليكوهين وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ما حجم الضرر الذي
تراه اصاب العلاقه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
انهم من الاهميه بمكان ان نقر ان التوتر
بين الحكومهتين قد
تراكم منذ عوده الحكم تذكر ان الرئيس
بايدن لم يتصل
بتنياهو بعد اعاده انتخاب به وهذا الطبع
دفع
لسلوك الطريق الخطا ندرك ان الحكومه
الامريكيه فيما بعد اداره ترامب قد
اتعاملت مع نتنياهو بطريقتها لو عدنا الى
اداره اوباما وحتى خلال سنوات فان بنيامين
نتنياهو كان
واضحا وشفاف بشان التدخل في سيسون
الداخليه الامريكيه ونراه اليوم لا سيما
في اليسار ان هناك
المشرعون الديمقراطي اكثر
يتصدون لي بني امين نتنياه قضايا عديده
يرون انها تمثل انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان
هذا ما كان ليحدث قبل 20 عام عندما كنت
ترى لا يمكن ان ترى سياسيين في الولايات
ينتقدون اسرائيل بسبب اللوبي الاسرائيلي
في الولايات المتحده
لكن هناك تغيير حاصل والتغيرات تزداد اكثر
فاكثر ولكن
نواصل السماع من اداره بيضه ان اسرائيل
تظل حليف وتواصل الولايات المتحده توفير
كميات هائله من الدعم العسكري والخارجي
لاسرائيل على الرغم ان التشققات واضحه في
العلاقات بين البلدين سيد روبين ما رايك
في هذا الكلام الذي قاله السيد المشكله
ليست بين اسرائيل وامريكا كدولتين بل
المشكله هي في التوجه السياسي المشكله بين
اليمين واليسار اليمين في اسرائيل الان
واليسار في امريكا الان
قد يكون هذا من بالمسببين
للبعد نسبي الذي نشهده اليوم
وهناك مقوله انه كل شيء في هذه الدنيا وفي
السياسات هو اشي شخصي لا ننسى موقف
نتنياهو المؤيد للترامب وهم يتذكرون ذلك
ويتحسبون على هذه الخلفيات يعني ليس هناك
في الاداره الامريكيه من يعتبر اسرائيل ما
يقلب لحقوق الانسان بل العكس نحن الدوله
الوحيده في الشرق الاوسط التي يسير فيها
جدال على ما هي الديمقراطيه كمصطلح وكعمل
في الميدان ليس هناك اي دوله في الشرق
الاوسط التي يتم فيها مثل هذا الذي يحصل
في صيد
والمساء نعم في اسرائيل هي اكثر كثير من
موضوع شخصي هنا وهنالك
ولذلك صحيح ما قاله ضيفك الكريم المصالح
الامريكيه مع اسرائيل كبيره جدا اسمحلي
فقط حتى نعطيه حيزا اكثر كذلك سيد هنا
اعود اليك ولكن هذا التضاد فيما يتعلق
باليمين واليسار الحكومه اليمينيه
الموجوده الان في اسرائيل
واضح الخلاف مع اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن هذا الخلاف صحيح انه امريكا
واسرائيل
ولكن كيف يؤثر هذا التضاد بين اليمين
واليسار على ملفات المنطقه
عندما ننظر الى المنطقه فالكثير من
البلدان التي تحيط باسرائيل لا تزال تنظر
الى الولايات المتحده على انها حامي
اسرائيل التي تواصل
الاستفاده الكبرى من
اي بلد في اكثر من اي بلد في المنطقه
بمفالك السعوديه ومصر من الولايات المتحده
وهذا لم يتغير نرى تصاعدي توتر كما اننا
نشهد عددا من المشرعين في الولايات
المتحده الذين يودون بتصريحات مناهضه
لاسرائيل دون اي تداعيات لذلك وطبعا
بنيامين نتنياهو كان طبعا لعبا كبيرا في
سياسه الداخليه الامريكيه اكثر من اي بلد
اخر ينظر الى نفسه على انه حليفه المتحده
وكان هناك الكثير من العداوه بين رئيس
بايدن ورئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامينها وعلى الرغم من ذلك في الولايات
المتحده
لم تقلل دعمها لاسرائيل على الاطلاق انظر
للتوترات بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
المتحده لها موقف لم يتغير حياه لذلك شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد اريك من واشنطن الخبير في
الشؤون الامريكيه ومن تل ابيب راؤوبين
باركوا الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
تويتر تشهد تراجعا كبيرا في مستوى مداخيل
الاعلانات القصه الكامله بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد شركه تويتر تشهد سقوطا
حرا على مستوى مداخل الاعلانات اخر
الارقام المعلنه بخصوص عائدات الاعلانات
كانت صادمه بشكل كبير فقد تراجعت عائلته
اعلانات تويتر في الولايات المتحده بنحو
59 وذلك للاسابيع الخمسه الاولى التي تلف
بدايه شهر ابريل وذلك نقلا عن صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه من غير المرجح ان
يتحسن هذا الاداء في اي وقت قريب نقلا عن
مصادر الصحيفه الامريكيه اما ايلون ماسك
فقد برر هذا التراجع بالضغط الشديد الذي
يمارسه المعلنون في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه على الشركه متهم اياهم بمحاوله
دفع تويتر الى الافلاس
الصحيفه حاولت رصد اسباب تراجع عائده
تويتر من الاعلانات وذكرت الصحيفه نقلا عن
موظفين مبيعات الاعلانات في تويتر ان
المعلنين باتوا يخشون من ارتفاع خطاب
الكراهيه على المنصه وتعد اعلانات تويتر
امرا بالغ الاهميه لتحقيق التوازن الملي
للشركه حيث ان مداخيل الاعلانات شكلت منذ
فتره طويله 90% من ارباح الشركه
[موسيقى]
تهديد حقيقي يحدق بالقطب الشمالي بعد
سنوات قليله دراسه حديثه خلصت الى ان
القطب الشمالي قد يكون خاليا من الجليد
البحري في الصيف في بدايات العقد المقبل
تقديرات جديده تبعث على القلق على اعتبار
ان التوقعات السابقه كانت تشير الى ان
ذوبان الجليد بشكل كلي في الصيف لن يحدث
الا بعد عقدين على الاقل
القطب الشمالي قد يكون خاليا من الجليد
البحري خلال الصيف في بدايات العقد المقبل
وذلك حسب دراسه نشرت على مجله نيتشرز
النتائج تشير لان اول سبتمبر من دون جديد
بحري سيحل بين الاعوام 2030 الى 2050
والسبب زياده انبعاثات الغازات الدافئه
الضاره
الموعد المرتقب ياتي قبل عقد من التوقعات
الصادره عن الهيئه المفوضه من الامم
المتحده
اختفاء جليدي ستكون له عواقب وخيمه
سيسرع من الاحترار في القطب الشمالي
وقد يزيد الظواهر الجويه المتطرفه مثل
موجات الحراره وحرائق الغابات كما قد يسهم
في ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر في جرينلاند
[موسيقى]
اظهر فيديو نشرته وكاله الامريكيه ثورانا
بركان كيلويا احد اكثر البراكين نشاطا على
الارض في جزيره بيج ايلاند احدى جزر هاواي
بالمحيط الهادئ
[موسيقى]
الساعه انتهت هذا التذكير بابرز اخبارها
من سد كخوفك الى خط لتصدير الامونيا
الفوضى تغرق اوكرانيا وتسمم اجوائها وسط
تبادل الاتهامات بين تياب وموسكو
في السودان الاشتباكات العنيفه تتجدد في
الخرطوم ومئاسي المرضى لا تتوقف بعد وفاه
جميع مرضى غسيل الكلى في مستشفى الجنينه
تجدد الخلاف بين اسرائيل وامريكا بعد
تصريحات كمال هاريس نائبه بايدن حول اصلاح
القضاء
حرائق كندا تصل نيويورك الدخان يغطي مبنى
الامم المتحده ويوقف رحلات جويه بسبب
انعدام الرؤيه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه دوت نت وعلى صفحاتنا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات